congratulations it's going so well on
blackish you're so funny on that show
your kind no I you really you are so
funny and I'm curious you know some
people get that way a little later in
life and some people just have it in
them as a kid were you as a when were
you making people laugh I'm already
making people laugh I used to get kicked
out of class for it
right and then also my yeah at dinner
time I really liked making my siblings
laugh yeah I also had a lot of energy
I'm like it's like all this all so far I
can channel everything how many siblings
did you have four siblings yeah when I
was growing up it was three because the
boys didn't come to I was 15 and 16 but
my sister's okay and at the dinner table
I used to sit next to my mom and then
Rhonda was next to me and chubby was
next to her and I'll just point out in
case anyone it lives under a rock it
doesn't know your mom the great Diana
Ross retro actively that's true yes
anyway what I'm saying is it's just
funny to picture Diana Ross at the head
of the table and you being a wiseass and
this makes it even worse so my mom was
always like okay so you clearly have a
lot of energy and are messing with
dinner so she would say sweetheart why
don't you go outside and get your
wiggles out and so we have glass doors
outside the dining table so I would be
like outside like bouncing around and
then I would like come back in and she
would be like are they out in everything
I don't think so I got more like them
all eating a quiet meal and you in the
background just bouncing around like an
idiot now I make a living at it right
yeah yeah or you know what today they
would medicate you you know it's had I
been you might be right right I'm
serious we live in an era now where they
would have medicated me they would have
had a blowgun in riddlin yeah
you know what my pediatrician said to my
mom when I was really little I don't
remember but I was told that I was like
a ball of fire and it was her job to
make sure that I went in the right
direction not the wrong one but that her
job was not to mess with the fire right
because I just I was like a big
personality ya know if I were I was what
I would have heavily sedated you you
know like you're very you're very
verbally funny and you have great facial
expressions but you're also physically a
funny person I think was it that's you -
yeah well I had to be to survive yeah I
don't know when I feel a feeling it
seems to go through all aspects of my
body I'm like a performance artist with
a feeling right like I'm sad dramatic
this could be a lot of things this could
be you're in a car accident I love you
yeah yeah you're always saying you're
very comfortable using your body I would
do yeah I would use my body to just make
people laugh because that's totally a
good way to use your body yeah but it's
sad when just taking off your clothes
does that I wouldn't have to do anything
I just go Wow
you